hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to unforgiving a
northern him we just uh we visited the
little ones that was nice happy about
that and we're gonna go well apparently
there's a clown that's making balloon
animals over there that's nice the
little ones are really gonna love that
so now we're gonna go to the hall of the
harp and I don't know what goes on at
the hall of the harp but I'm pretty sure
it ain't gonna be too friendly so let's
find out shall
okay you talkin about the harp now why
would you hide the harm that's just mean
belt is broken listen to one of the
blacksmith oh you mean that belt I think
I know what of what we're talking about
because of theft the cabinet is locking
the key is with the Guardian oh you mean
that key haha alright wait there's
another piece of paper here do you need
a tongue on an eyeball because I got
that started the gasoline in power first
all right
dunzo ones Oh looks like me got the
month oh if you know what I'm talking
about
huh I already got it what oh okay let me
pump this a few times oh yeah let me get
that gas flowing bumpety bumpety oh yeah
get that pump äj-- alright how about now
oh yeah yeah oh oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
ah now we're kicking it into high gear
oh yeah oh yeah oh now I got it oh I've
got it you ever seen how big my brain is
never wondered why my head so huge it's
because I'm really smart okay don't
question it I'm good at solving puzzles
so leave it at that it's all fact
scientifically speaking anyway
carrying on don't know where I'm going
but I know what's happening I mean
what's happening is that I'm marching
towards my imminent demise and trying to
run away from the fears of my brother's
death being my fault oh whoa oh shut up
Oh No thank you okay wow I something
tells me it's absolutely happening you
are all tree creatures and it's just as
bad as it sounds okay glad I cleared
that up for you now I gotta go find this
harp glad I've been able to see her not
again no no no no no no no nnn-no oh ah
water great ooh
this person just planned for their house
to be like this okay all right good for
you
planning for the inevitable is a good
thing I think
we don't throw some
okay who came for what now okay that's
probably the hall of the heart but I'm
gonna see what's over here I think I
missed the building back on the way but
I'll hit it on the way back okay okay
all right well ease you acknowledge your
failures and when you're able to
reconcile with that then you can truly
make progress in life so you're already
taking the first step so that's good I'm
very proud of you
that's locked ahh
Torvald can't find the frame with the
hidden song alright ooh by the roots of
the trees they dwell the three that spin
the threads of life some call them which
is well of those claims they're fair
maidens from the Giants they who
powerfully weave all of our destinies
cool I guess okay oh that's terrible
okay wait I didn't even see the head
poking out that's that's even worse
ah no one did their dishes in this town
uh an even better chamber ponds there's
another naked lady
Ruth found dead body was found with the
scratch marks around the face
specifically around the eyes Oh was I
there did I do that because I seem to
have an affinity for eyes whoa I heard
that
all right I don't know what these things
I'm collecting are this is weird
okay boertie Brahman ham Abbas okay sure
we'll go with that one hmm I don't like
this at all nothing about me likes any
of what's happening in here there's got
to be a reason for all of this
like who's Ruth and why does that matter
and it seems like people would probably
have more to worry about than just a few
scratch marks around your eyes if you go
missing in the woods hence the fact that
you're kind of dead and all like that
whole thing hello alright it all just
seems to be bad in this town like no
matter what way you slice it everything
here seems to be awful in every way in
every possible conceivable way so why
did they stay why would they stay why
would anybody stay here this is a
terrible terrible terrible place to be
yeah terrible hunter is that awful all
the way through
one for started it indeed okay Oh Isis
the kettlebell studio good okay great
excellent one I'm so glad I got that the
key the harp was formed from oh I'm not
even gonna try with that one itself
inserted with magical golden carved with
holy runes the dwarves gave the harp to
Freya who plucked two pitched strands
from her golden hair and used them as
strings so the magic could flow through
the powerful instruments righty then I
did not mean to like this but okay I'm
gonna
fate has deemed it worthy ah what room
is this
the theater room sure I'm finding a lot
of these things the holy duty ava miss
you okay weird where David where David
go huh did something happen to Ava
guys I got a bad feeling about Ava I
don't know about you guys but methinks
Ava might be dead wasn't there anything
in this chest
okay oh that oh that's awful if that's a
face that's awful methinks it might not
be a face me thinks it might be a
waterfall but it looks like the horrible
face lady from it oh do not like that
ah good okay it's a screaming mouth and
an eye don't tell me that's anything but
that it's got a bullet hole in it I
don't know why all right can't see
anything
that's horrible okay what do we got here
anything yeah there we are Oh to Johann
Larsson Ruth Ruth okay
well Ruth is very dead so we know that
for a fact and then we can move on with
our lives once we take that knowledge
the power of runes Otis Oden sacrificed
himself and suffered for knowledge about
the runes the powerful symbols with
which humans can bend reality assume
that the stones and powerful places
which channel their powers can be found
okay
but why though but why ye alright I'm a
light another one cuz it can't see [ __ ]
as long as everybody just stays in their
place everything's gonna be fine yeah I
kill to have a flashlight in this time I
gotta imagine that somebody's got a
flashlight in this place I mean they got
electricity that somehow still magically
running even though I'm pretty sure all
this place is purely run by runes and
magic nothing is as it seems I imagine
hello oh good runes are these the power
runes oak oh hey that hit everything
about those eyes staring at me in these
things as if it was waiting for me to
open these drawers which I bet you were
you are judging me very harshly is there
more eyes over here no thanks is it a
mouth ah Ruth is dead
yes Ruth is dead indeed ah the harp just
lying around who trusts that not I not
even a little bit that is not the harp
oh nice belt this is a great belt guys
quality leather alright well that's not
good I don't wanna what if I don't wanna
hmm you ever think about that dick hole
ass bag you ever think about that oh you
know you know I feel like we've reached
an impasse here I've got a heart that I
very much enjoy and you've got an ass
for a face so really who's the loser
I guess I gotta put it back all righty
then what I need
fire fire and blued so let me get this
straight you want fire and blued I've
got an eyeball in a tongue or one of
those gonna count what do I have here
what do I have what do I have to give
you oh no no don't
why no don't why you didn't know that
was necessary and fire all right
fair trade I guess sure go with fat man
you know is this something that just
like all Swedish people just know
inherently they know if you get trapped
in a walk in the woods from a town from
the 1940s and a alter just whispers to
you when you try to take a magical harp
fire and blood you know immediately of
course alright this seems like a fair
deal my mom told me about this one
[Music]
do you enjoy that one guys and you like
that one and I bet that was pretty I
don't know what I did but okay righty-ho
then right he ho okay I get it I get it
I don't get it okay I hate this this is
the worst that's gonna end very badly
for me I can't go that way apparently
alright here we go
we're gonna go outside and we're gonna
play some harp cuz that's what I do
oh okay all right you guys you guys
ready for a ditty you guys ready for a
sweet ditty
wait hang on I get it I get it
me I what I get it oh yeah okay all
right good start good start
wonk all right even better started all
right wonk wonk wonk
all right good we're good and then wonk
no I goofed it I hang on I got started
over wonk wonk wonk wonk wonk wonk
it's like Legend of Zelda link to the
ocarina you know what I'm saying about I
think you do
yeah I'm a real gamer guys I love to guy
excuse you what did you are you were you
the tree person did you just get up and
leave that tree is that is that
something that you guys know you're
still there okay all right just visiting
then I I suppose all right okay a little
concerning but you know a I think it's
all right I'll let bygones be bygones
and just don't do it again next time and
I'll forgive you
you try to get all punching your dick oh
I'm on the wrong side how did I get here
gonna jump oh ow my ankles
that was a horrible error that I
committed are ye
what where oh my god
oh my god hey lady lady lady not in
front of the children
good golly Jimmy Christmas you know you
are you are a few attitudes away from
getting a smack okay don't
are you the naked lady that was running
through the woods and if you are keep up
the good work I guess you know they're
really writing about you you know your
art people are starting to take it
seriously
and I really appreciate that
[Laughter]
that's a weird music in my brain
right now I'm right here
okay all right I get
okay all right whatever you say all
right you want to hear I'll give you a
little sweet ditty da da da da da da did
you like it
something tells me you didn't like it
okay fine then I think I gotta go this
way to be able to get to the thing not
Harbison sure there's these weird walls
everywhere now this is just a [ __ ]
all right so where is the magical place
I guess I could consult the map and be
nice
I'm very near I need to cross the river
and then take a left that's what I need
to do okay we'll do that I'm gonna do
that right now actually I'm getting away
from you
if you want to catch me you got to speed
up it's all I gotta say about that some
tells me you might be speeding up I
can't tell what's an owl and what's a
hooting lady hmm
at least I got what I need so I guess
I'll be on my way then all right II
already already already already already
okay all right I think I got this I
think I got this so I need to play
[Music]
No
okay so I don't know the melody do i
okay okay so I gotta find something else
there's gotta be something else here to
be able to find I thought that was blood
on the ground to be able to actually
find the melody to play to be able to
know the thing to get the boat to come
across from Ruth wait no rune Ruth is
dead rune may not be dead yet let me
consult a map nice map Oh consult a map
oh oh there are you naked how naked are
you extremely is the answer don't scream
in my ear lady I got a harp if you
wanted I guess hey Wow ow ow my butt why
did you bite my butt why did you bite my
butt stop screaming at me and answer the
question why'd you bite my butt don't
bite my butt oh I'm dead I'm sorry I'm
so dead I'm so dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead or not okay I guess I'm okay
all right everything's good in the world
okay all right cool great all right so
what do I need to do something about the
key I've already gotten that key for rod
storage wait rune okay wait of this road
to the left maybe that's the building
that I didn't quite go in just near the
clock tower there's gonna be a it's
gotta be a something there there was
also another wasn't there another
building I don't like us out of this
okay how about this yeah this one I
couldn't Oh
let me in please I've got the got the
magical harp
[Music]
wait oh whoa hey
you are very naked oh okay hi hello lady
well I died I did indeed I was trying to
find out a ditty and it did didn't work
it didn't work okay whatever you say
did I go in here I don't know if I went
in here oh I definitely didn't go in
here because this is or below hidden
worlds one there's some speculation
about whether or not there are other
worlds and dimensions worlds where the
rules of our world do not apply where
reality is spread thin over the branches
of that word that I can't pronounce and
I'm not even going to try oh why oh
hello Oh close that door
horrible horrible Oh
scary baby all right well this is bad
what is that she's coming yeah no
kidding I I'm well aware of that dead
cows found in Penn's Benson and found in
tyre okay all right
Wow no don't blew me please I don't want
to be rude you gonna leave me alone lady
Rhea ooh
Wow scary scary please leave me alone
[Music]
No
[Laughter]
nope I'm gonna make a run for it there's
a bad idea but here we go anyway
there we go anyway we go anywhere we go
anyway all right I don't know where she
was but it was very scary yeah we was so
Jerri
okay what's at the top of this hill oh I
hate it I hate everything about it I
hate everything about that I think about
that is terrible no no no I can feel
flow I guess aah whoa big shoes okay all
right ah so this is the farm yes oh the
farm where all the cows were very dead
yeah well bunch of matches okay good for
me all right why did I come in here to
get trapped and die that's what I came
in here for yeesh yes yes
is there another building here that I
can get into hello you why are you
blocking my way come on don't oh whoa
whoa girl
whoa whoa lady is on roots and I am NOT
doing good okay there's got to be
another place to go right what is this I
don't think I've seen this no that's the
clock tower was that there was that like
the storage thing no that was like no
that was storage okay so that was a
storage there's also like a north door I
want to see what that's about if this is
the right way towards it nope is this
where I just came from also there god
damn thumping it's weird because I can
like tune it out and then it'll just
start rushing back
oh hello okay they can see me he no
kidding the eyes I've seen them - don't
come in sorry already inside him
sorry Church of Gaul of ours burned
blaze its Gabby from a start santorum
captured where are these newspapers
coming from runic writing a rune another
rune a bag of runes so many runes the
Living Mountain these enormous creatures
can be mistaken for mountains at first
sight however with a little care they
can be examined a bit closer on
occasions their enormous eyes are open
[Music]
whoo whoo whoo whoo whoo hey why why why
why nah no how about no no no no no no
no
no no no no in fact in fact big no big
no on that one big bong can no hey it's
the windmill ah okay alright what is
this okay great got this honestly no I
have not so I'm very sorry I cannot help
you
yeesh all right let's find out what's in
this building that I had to avoid do not
whoo whoo oh hi oh hi oh hi oh there's
no reason to be in here is there okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry ah
this isn't been convenient for me oh
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing there's nothing here there's no
reason for this all right jump over this
rock evasive jump please okay all right
we're fine jump jump everybody's up jump
evasive jump
these evasive jobs aren't working Oh woo
woo woo woo
I think that's the sound of the
all-clear oh no it is not
oh I'm dead I'm dead oh this I'm gonna
root here there's a Rooney lady
it's a Rudy let me live my life I'm
gonna die all right you know I just Gelb
a jelly arcades go be Wow
oh maybe I gotta like sneak maybe I
should be sneaky huh maybe I should do
that anyway I'll do that next time
because I'm all out of time for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching
oh stop shouting in my ear thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know how I did and let me know what you
think down the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]